now I understand that it looks you know
like a continuous fight but really
you're stopping you're applying makeup
Eco what are you doing in between takes
because you've got to keep that momentum
up there punching you they're applying
new wounds what are you doing to keep
yourself going as an actor listening to
Toni Braxton again fighting passenger
and house number adrenaline it then yeah
consent of the top brass column seven
economy second pass addition abyss fight
interest karana big hits at Lompoc
Robbie
missus again then Maki Rama Posse but
then I can then I set up you think that
was like a joke which song break my
heart
okay oh that's actually I have something
for you here on Baron kana own took
member Libby baaaack film Hollywood no
missile away can you appear a billion
under Baron Connor own took memoir Levi
banyak film Hollywood huh yeah
definitely come on Keenan
you